eh bien, c'est arrivé au cours des 10 dernières
années,
c'est un miracle, je suis même assis ici maintenant,
j'ai une seconde chance,
je vais en profiter
mais j'ai besoin de toi avec moi Pete,
tu vas guérir le monde
[Musique]
les gars  c'est mon meilleur ami Harry hé
content de te rencontrer, bon travail hein, je
vais encore avoir le temps pour le tutorat nous allons le
découvrir
je ne savais pas qu'il y avait des ours dans ces
bois
AMJ j'ai un autre nom pour toi Craven
il est ici sur une sorte  de chasse
tu sais si tu as besoin de moi je suis juste à un coup de fil
sais ce que tu as pris pour moi
et bien dont Miles parle c'est comment être un
meilleur Spider-Man
l'enfer se passe avec Pete il n'est pas
lui-même va l'aider
c'était notre  je rêve que
nous allons tuer le monde
[Musique]